monsieur rodriguez bonjour jean l'impôt
cohen voilà je suis acteur réalisateur
du flambeau bah écoutez je vous appelle
tout simplement pour vous remercier
d'avoir vu la série vous n'avez pas
regardé d'accord c'est vos enfants vous
en foutez vous ne d'accord c'est pas
votre came d'accord je comprends pas
bonjour bonjour je suis camille la
responsable de l'aménagement dans les
nouveaux locaux
bonsoir baril
bienvenue au canal + soient tous
les problèmes car
3400 tu m'as dit là ça s'arrête à 3220
quand vous avez des bureaux magnifique
qui ne sont pas encore prêts
tu veux savoir comment est ce qu'on
voyait les choses la répartition de vos
bureaux mais on a pensé à quelque chose
en fait refermée ie6 parce que
l'accélération très grosse accepte garde
escaliers et n'a derrière vous rentrez
dans la rédaction et rendez vous aux
produits à gauche les salles de montage
unis pensent et celle de l'imprimante et
40 a cédé
à la jet j'appelais les abonnés qui ont
regardé ma série de faits pour les
remercier je pense à ces classes de la
wii tasséré le trou
là torches
flambeaux flammes feu de paille
tu trouves tu fais ta série alors j'ai
entendu et oui c'est pour ça que je
m'installe
ça la plante est oui et ouais mais moi
c'est pas une télé réalité où c'est
écrit
oui c'est une autofiction ça tu veux ton
propre route où elle était tellement
original pour l'humour histoire du
jamais vu
ça va plus c'est les jours que vous
faites là et ben vous à aix et le bureau
du patron ici oui bon je vous laisse
vous
aussi
oui camille pour la sécu il ya deux
potentiels squatters dans le bureau du
patron de la bastide installé quechua
chargé parce qu'ils sont eux dans ces
deux là je les connais je suis hyper
content de te vois mais là sincèrement
ça tant de mal j'ai mon film j'ai une
série que j'attaque ça j'ai pas beaucoup
de temps comme ça on t'a préparé un truc
c'est pas possible que tu kiffes pas à
regarder mbam le plv c'est comme ça
s'appelle un grandeur nature bam
gastambide je peux parler et attend
regarde la photo que je préfère je te
cache pas que je les demande et aussi
pour chez moi il ya bien sûr b disque
d'or ça regarde la suite arrive à mettre
sur 50 ton prochain film tu auras 70
millions de budget vas-y essaye vas-y
essaye vas-y vas-y vas-y étaient
calmes et maintenant s'il te plaît tammy
arrêt petit a besoin combien de temps
pour l'écrire tout ce que j'ai pour
cette porte et je te prends mais elle
est folle elle et pour le monde 3 je
vais revenir mais pour l'instant je peux
pas rester arrête
rock oui ok je te libères vrai tu me
passes des gones
qu est ce qu elle déconne aller
travailler bien
bonjour voila on cherche des gens connus
à vous cherchez des gens connus bah on
l'a bien fait se rencontrer aussi je
suis toujours y non je ne cherche pas
déjà connu mais
si charles gimat vous connaissez des
gens crier non je connais pas des gens
connus je suis connue
ok vous après j'adore les sushi
sushi
cohiba vous éclater je suis groupe le
plus grand méchant en fait trop bien non
mais c'est pas que je fais trop bien
c'est moi c'est ma voix c'est gros
[Musique]
accident non c'est juste de test on voit
si on peut résister au choc face à tous
les événements qu'on va couvrir tu vois
tu pourrais essayer moi je pense je suis
pas la cible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
super saison
et camille vous pouvez venir on a un
problème à la cantine en fait j'ai un
petit problème pour mon collègue c'est
mon co auteur en fait vous n'avez pas
beaucoup de repas végétariens et ils
crèvent la dalle on doit écrire tout
l'après midi donc d'accord il a rempli
sa fille la fiche pour les régimes
alimentaires spéciaux les énergies des
restrictions pas rempli la fiche toi
un petit crumble vous n'êtes pas autre
chose et pas du foin qu'est ce qui
s'passe alex ça va varier avec
jean-claude ben il n'y a pas de plats
végétariens quant à la nouvelle cantine
donc
et est ce que tu as pensé aux jeunes
gens clown j'ai fait mon chéri non ouais
non c'est pas ton délire je jure il
bouffe il faut qu'on trouve une solution
ok déjà mais notre côté tous les
suppléments légumes carottes betteraves
que ça ok point quoi du foin dire à une
cantine du point
j'ai joué dans les films la maison
d'annie sa bonne foi et en fait nous
organiser une conférence pour parler du
désir de la femme et de son droit à
disposer de son corps je vois tu rien et
du coup tu souhaites que j'intervienne
dans quelle province
j'ai besoin que tu me réserve le dit
ariane hockey pauline en passant
quotidienne ce à dire que clic c'est
tous les soirs si on passe tous les
soirs mouloud il n'aura pas l'énergie du
coup on a une idée de génie avec dumont
on a créé une invention révolutionnaire
un générateur de mouloud achour tu as le
hall de mouloud on dirait michel denisot
à poil mais c'est le aug minutes après
on a le skinny mouloud assez le moule de
la compta là va te dire gros mouloud
mais non mouloud tout corps ont une
nature peinture et route qu'on connaît
et le dernier le meilleur mon chouchou à
des militants sur le tour
c'est ça en gare on peut même de générer
sur place
nous avons ouï dire que se tourner de
l'autre côté du portail la série marie
antoinette ce serait possible de pouvoir
rentrer dans la série on connaît des
risques du bordel alors moi j'ai coché
marie antoinette on va faire des
comédies tout notre ville confort vous
avez la chance d'être dans l'antre de
canal+ est amené à rencontrer des gens y
pensent on sort son portable et enfin
c'est ce
qu'on peut croire
aujourd'hui vous êtes à quel étage là
antoine je ne sais pas et c'est très
drôle parce que j'ai l'impression de
monter en descendant ou de descendre en
goûtant au bon tu prends des charades
c'est cette chaire a joué gros vous
énervez pas monsieur toile et groland
c'était très rigolo mais va falloir
sortir j'aimerais bien avoir d'autres
all blacks avaient écouté je serais
passé mais moi je peux rien faire
d'autre si la responsable de
l'emménagement je suis pas sûr pas
question
tu sais pas je vais très bien quelqu'un
qui pourrait acheter
10 qui ça
sature
merci à tous que je lâche et non mais
philippe je n'ai pas su non c'est pas du
tout bon c
phil est ce que je vais qu'est-ce que ça
là philippe qu'est ce qui se passe à
qu'est ce qui se passe là bordel si les
professeurs m'ont immédiatement
une offre jugée plus facile
[Musique]
perso je n'y a pas de place ça rentre ça
fausse la rampe la
savait toujours pas